what's up battlefield fans we're gonna
take a look at battlefield one turning
tides DLC which we were able to see
recently in the community test
environment now keep in mind this is
called a white box environment where
textures aren't on the map yet and what
you see here might change before the
final DLC release turning tides brings
two new maps cape hell's in Aceh baba
cape hell sees the return of conquest
assault to battlefield and is a pretty
fun map where the attacking team has to
make a short landing with landing craft
and drop ramps and all then they have to
fight their way up the hill and take all
the objectives to push the defenders off
the map
Hachi baba the other smaller map that we
saw it didn't have any vehicles on it it
was a very I would say Zerg rush map
pretty much the team that stayed in the
biggest group just steamrolled everyone
more exciting our new weapons which
everybody likes in battlefield assault
gets the m12 p16 Auto pistol which i
think is just the gun from Robocop and
that thing is a hell of a lot of fun
it's particularly good to fire from the
hip they also get the c96 trench pistol
which has a pretty high-capacity
magazine really good accuracy and fast
rate of fire thoroughly enjoyed both of
those finally the assault also gets a
new anti-air rocket to put into their
launcher which is deadly against
infantry the medic gets a short and long
range new DMR which I thought was ok
support gets a browning style machine
gun which again I thought is ok but it's
so hard to compete with that starting
Lewis gun which is my opinion just kind
of better than everything still and the
Scout gets to Arisaka and Carcano rifles
overall I had a lot of fun on Cape Hel's
which to me is everything that a
battlefield map should be a theme
assaulting a beach fun objectives like a
castle and large vehicles like airplanes
and dreadnaughts and siege cannons
octi bob is probably more for players
who just come to the core battlefield
experience for the shooting alright
let's get to some gameplay at
battlefield one turning tides dlc you
can make up your own mind
[Music]
[Music]
we have taken objective photo
listen
laughter
Oh
motion body cavity
[Music]
sennosuke yard of chocolate
[Music]
we have taken objective Edward
the slippery roadways are does the enemy
has the other hand
got a little pity
you